哈囉,大家好呀,我是小专临
今天想跟你們分享一下我的眼球保養
其實說眼睛會暴露一個人的年齡
我覺得倒不如說是眼神會暴露一個人的年齡
其實我跟朋友還照
然後他們都會問我
為什麼我的眼睛看起來是亮亮的
然後眼神感覺很清楚
那我自己的眼睛本身就是比較有神的那種
那今天就來跟你們分享一下
我是做了什麼還用我吃了什麼
都是乾貨絕無廣告
建議你們先點在收藏
那首先我的勢力是非常好的
從小學人1.0到後來讀書的時候是1.2到現在我的眼睛是1.5
也就是說我可以看到勢力表的到數第2牌
那說到我是做的什麼呢
我就給你們分享我最真實的一個經歷
我是在小學醫院級的時候就非常認真地做眼罷建策
其實現在小書很火的那個眼部波經
就和我們上學時候做的眼罷建策是有一曲同工的
都是對我們的眼部進行一個放鬆
我不知道現在的實際上還會不會要求學生去做眼罷建策
但我那個時候是一天會做了兩次
我一直從小學1.0做到高三
我做了12年
而且我每次做草都是非常的認真
其實那個時候我們班很多同學已經不會去做眼罷建策
但是我就是非常的認真
就很前安全的在做
而且我現在眼睛就算感到提供的時候
我也會去做眼罷建策
那眼罷建策他就是可以讓你的眼睛放鬆下來
他放鬆下來的你眼睛就不會有那麼的疲憐
沒有那麼容易充血
那你經常做這個眼部的這種放鬆
你的勢力他就可以保持住
起碼的不會讓你勢力變差
這樣眼睛就會看起來比較清楚
人會看起來感覺很有精神
因為你的眼睛是亮亮的很有神的
所以我覺得現在的眼部玻璉
你們是可以做起來的
不說他對區黑眼圈和眼帶的效果
他對這個勢力起碼是非常好的
如果這樣沒有寶寶也可以租出小朋友去做起來
然後我還有一個保持眼部清澈的法寶
就是吃的就是一個蠻美碗的視頻拍的
那這個蠻美碗我已經吃了
把它就是吃到第一了
那就是在幾個月之前
那我可能是每天看手機看電腦看多了我的眼睛
就特別的干涉
就算我順保了十二個小時醒來
我看一分鐘手機我的眼睛就受不了
就是非常的難受那種只能必相眼睛休息
那眼睛內就寫了任何疲憐
也很顯老
我那個時候也是想了很多辦法
我每天都會站你的蠻美果之後
然後做眼寶件操
第一內容眼要睡
但那一次就是都不管用
然後我就看完碗
他當時推薦了就是這個蠻美碗
那我就半心看你就是在網上下單了
結果了
我才吃了三四天的樣子
我的眼睛干涉了那個症狀就完全好了
就是眼睛非常非常的舒服
當時就是已經有好友好友好友
沒有感受我的眼睛有那麼的輕鬆了
我覺得他的這個劍效真的好快
我真的就是吃了三四天眼睛就好了
就知道後來我就才在繼續玩
一天的手機我的眼睛也不會感覺很平貝
而且他也不難吃
他裡面都是那種花青素
還量非常高的美果
就算是三四天的小孩也可以吃
我覺得吃這個是蘋果買一些
貴價的眼霜要更有效的
而且我覺得吃了他之後的皮膚也變好了
我現在練就是很練
我不知道有沒有他的功勞
但是我以前皮膚是沒有現在這麼好的
我想說真的有一件這種看法的上法
其實我以前是一個比較冰的人
就是我不太相信你就吃這種東西
真的對皮膚會有好充滿
會能看得到效果嗎
但我覺得他真的是
讓我看到效果了
所以分享給你
我沒有廣告
真的是我自己買的
而且我錄著他視頻之前
我又下單買了一期
拜拜